everyone in the world by now must have
heard about the tragic oil spill in the
Gulf of Mexico or leak of oil continuing
and we thought that it would be
interesting to show you what crude oil
is really like after much searching
around the University my colleague Sam
found some samples there here you can
see some of them beginning to leak
already and there's a terrible stink of
oil in here so we're go in the lab and
have a look at them there so oil is
quite complicated material it's formed
under the ground at great depths from
layers of plant material and animal
material which is compressed by the
rocks and the weight of the rocks oil is
not the same from everywhere over the
world because it just depends how the
rocks in that particular place had been
treated over millions of years some
crude oil that comes out to the ground
is really runny like almost like water
and others is so thick that it's even
thicker than molasses all Trippel in the
Gulf of Mexico the oil is being released
into the sea so let's see what happens
when you mix oil and water so here we
have some water all crude oil is less
dense than water so it floats so even if
you release it at the bottom the sea is
going to float up to the surface so here
again I've got the North Sea oil the
rather runny oil and if we fill up some
oil here put it to the bottom of the sea
and now release it slowly
so you can see straight away that the
oil is floating on the surface in a very
thin layer if you look at it from the
side you can hardly see it at all so you
can immediately see the sort of cleanup
problem that you're going to have
because the oil covers a huge area but a
very thin layer on the surface of the
sea so there's not very much the scooped
up in went in in one place and the other
point about oil is that it repels water
there's the famous saying oil and water
don't mix now the big problem comes with
wildlife particularly Birds the reason
that birds can sit on the water and
don't sink is because they have oil on
their feathers natural oils that repel
the water when a duckling is first
hatched from the egg if you put it in
the water it sinks it takes several days
for the oil to go on the feathers so
they can swim so therefore when birds
feathers come into contact with crude
oil there's a problem and I've got some
feathers here these are from a pillow so
don't worry I haven't killed the bird to
get it and here's some feathers and
let's just see what happens if we put
the feathers into the oil and you can
see it's like a miracle
it cleans up all the oil but for the
poor bird all the water repellent
properties of its feathers are spoiled
you've got this thick oil which make the
feathers clump together the water gets
to the bird skin and they get cold
eventually they can dive hypothermia and
of course they can't fly because their
feathers aren't fluffy anymore the way
that you can clean up the birds and
remove the oil is by using so-called
surfactant this is essentially like soap
what it does is to allow the oil to form
tiny tiny droplets which are essentially
do no harm
difficulty is that the surfactants that
removed the crude oil also removed the
oil from the birds feathers people know
how to clean that water but it is the
scale of the problem you're talking
about slicks of oil that are covering
hundreds if not thousands of square
miles